les examens doivent pouvoir se dérouler
dans l'enseignement du second degré
début juin 1968
après un mois de grève de manifestations
et de lycées bloqués le déroulement du
baccalauréat y complètement bousculer
certains élèves veulent le deccan et la
deuxième proposition décidé hier est un
report du baccalauréat au mois de
septembre sous une forme à discuter et
nous demandons à tous de venir discuter
d'autres élèves imagine qu'il soit donné
à tous ce à quoi s'opposent les
associations de parents d'élèves
j'ai entendu hier une proposition faite
le baccalauréat pour tous cette année
c'est pas sérieux c'est démagogique
nous ne marchons pas nous pensions que
doivent avoir le bac ce qui mérite
d'avoir le bac
finalement le gouvernement décide
quelques jours avant les épreuves que le
baccalauréat se déroulera sous forme
d'épreuves orales
chaque matière à l'oral en une seule
journée avec le résultat le soir même
fin juin 1968 les lycéens français sont
confrontés à ce nouveau bac vous avez
passé le battre aujourd'hui je les
passais hier gelé pas moi je m'estime ne
pas être lésés mais enfin certains l'ont
été puisque c'est une question de sujets
en tire un sujet au sort il est facile
où il est dur vous venez de passer
quelques unes des épreuves de ce bac 68
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je pense que du bien enfin je sais que
le râle c'est assez bien alors monsieur
ces épreuves orales comment se sont
elles passées ce matin
on al'avantage sur les critiques on peut
dialoguer avec le professeur et c'est
plus facile si réd affaire moi je
préférais l'écrit c'est une question
d'optimiser si on est plus ou moins
timide en plus ou moins mais très
rapidement une interrogation est-ce que
ce bac 100% orale de 1968 à la même
valeur que l'examen des années
précédentes
on dit que les professeurs ont reçu des
consignes bien d'une chance c'est vrai
ça je vais vous n'avez pas l'impression
d'avoir un mini bac à bac un peu diminué
nous on ne semble pas pour le moment pas
encore si vous réussissez est-ce que
vous ne s'estimerait pas que vous êtes à
une sous bâche ollières non toute façon
je m'estime heureuse de l'avoir eue et
ils ont été 80 1,3 pour cent à être
reçue contre 62 % l'année précédente et
67 % l'année suivante le bac 1968 aura
toujours la réputation d'avoir été
donnée
[Musique]
oh